FLEURY E JUST GOVERNMENT A PIEC.
OPPORTUNITY.
BIG ASSIST ON THE GAME-WINNING
GOAL. WERE CHANGING AS
THE HONDA DEFENSE MAN KUEMPER TA
WIN THE OTHER NIGHT?
>> HE WAS
HE WILL WALK AND SHOT.
BLOCKED AWAYS WERE GOOD ENERGY.
A BROKEN STICK. AND NEWHOOKER GS
AUBE-KUBEL ANDND OF YEAR
THAT HE HOPED RUSH.
>> PATRICK KANE WAS IN THE F
BACK THROUGH MURRAY.
STEERS IT BACKCK
DROPS IT OFF.
MacDERMID INTO T AHEAD BY McCAB.
TOEWS.
THROWS IT FARRIST SHOT WIDE TO .
PICKED UP BY AND GIVE CHASE.
CENTERING PASS.
KANE.
KKKO TRIED TO FLOW IT ON NET.
>> I REALLY LOVE THAT GRAPHIC,
TOO.
CO -- GEICO.COM.SO FAR, THE AT
SKATE.
HE WENT DOWN AWKWARDLY. NONCHAL.
THAT -- UP
AND DOWN, DISJOINTED A LITTLE
BIT.
THERE'S A QUICK CENTERING PASS.
PENALTY COMING UP, 13:25
THE ICE.
BUMPS IT HIM
RIGHT HERE. STREAKED THROUGH FL.
KADRI IS GONNA GET THE WHEN -- S
2-1. YOU.
BUT FOR SOME REASON, THIS G
>> MIKKO RANTANEN!
WAITS, WAIT, WAITS OVER.
BY THAT
STEERS IT OFF MacKINNON.
DANCES, SHOOTING,
ICING WAVED.
LANDESKOG GOT UP AND ON IT.
CALL.
RANTANEN ALL BY HIS